Musik Wenn wir jetzt hier fast einfach grob in die Richtung des Mikrofons sprechen, dann sind wir eigentlich, glaube ich, alle glücklich mit dabei. Wunderbar. So, das funktioniert. Ah, okay. Gut, ich habe jetzt nur auf das hier geachtet. Wir hatten schon die krassesten Gäste hier. Das ist völlig egal, das ist nur mit dem Peelauto richtig. Wir hatten schon die krassesten Gäste hier, die haben nur leider nicht ins Mikrofon gesprochen. Deswegen sind die Folgen immer so ein bisschen blöd. Jennifer Lopez, ein grossartiger Gast. Ja, ja, Yoshi war hier. Aber leider nicht ins Mikrofon gesprochen. Ich habe einfach einen Gamer-Gag gemacht. Einfach dachte, passt, Yoshi. Ist das für dich noch ein Thema, Yoshi? Ja, ich habe eine Wii. Ich habe eine Wii. Das ist bei mir zu Hause im Schrank ungeliebt. Ja. Liegt sie da. Neben Satre?
Sag mal so, Nintendo hat ein sehr grosses Ego.
Sie wollen, dass ihre Spiele in einer besonderen Art
gespielt werden.
Und das siehst du schon
einfach daran, dass sie zum Beispiel immer noch glauben,
sie müssen, ich meine, der einzige
Grund, warum sie Konsolen herstellen, ist,
weil sie wollen, dass du deren Spiele
auf deren Konsolen spielst. Und die gehen halt selber davon aus, dass ihre Spiele Zelda, Mario und so weiter so unfassbar geil sind, was sie ja auch stellenweise sind, dass das halt genug Konsolen über die Ladentische bringt, dass dadurch ein Weltunternehmen sich trägt. Mit der Wii wurde da halt einfach eine Marktlücke entdeckt und die haben da halt ihren Profit für die nächsten 20.000 Jahre eingefahren, die haben damit so viel Asche verdient. Und da hast du halt jetzt das Problem, ich finde, Nintendo sollte mal sich mehr so wie Disney sehen und sagen, okay, wir haben einfach ganz starke IPs, wir haben bekannte Charaktere, Mario ist eine der bekanntesten Figuren überhaupt. Ich glaube sogar, bekannter als Mickey Mouse habe ich mal gehört. Bekannter als Jesus vor allem. Ja, also krass einfach, unfassbar krass, ja, und beide Italiener. Aber das Krasse ist halt, dass Nintendo diese unfassbar starken kulturellen Manifeste hat mit Zelda, mit Mario und so weiter und so fort. Mit Tendogs. Metroid, sowas, die halt richtig viele Units verkauft haben. Und ihr fühlt euch nicht passé, oder? Nee, überhaupt nicht, überhaupt nicht. Ich finde es spannend, aber ich bin einfach lost gerade in diesem Thema. Ich meine, wir schneiden das alles raus, aber reden wir weiter. Lasst dich nicht aufhalten. Ich stelle mir mal vor, ich habe gerade im Spaß rausgehauen mit Jesus, aber es ist nicht eine lustige Vorstellung, um sich vor Augen zu führen, wie abstrus eigentlich diese ganze Jesus-Bibel-Nummer ist, wenn man sich vorstellt, dass einfach, wenn man sagt, dass diese ganze Mario, diese ganze Mario-Kosmos, wenn das jetzt unsere Religion wäre, also warum nicht? Ich meine, es ist genauso nachzuvollziehen wie... Jeden Sonntag, jetzt zu essen. Ja, ich finde das eine wahnsinnig lustige Vorstellung für die Absurdität der Religion eigentlich. Also das führt sich auf ein Buch zurück, alles kann sich auf ein Videospiel zurückfinden. Ja, ein Videospiel ist ja ein viel besseres Medium eigentlich als... Es ist ein viel cooleres Also ein viel grösserer Wiederspielwert eigentlich. Also das alles führt sich auf ein Buch zurück, alles kann sich auf ein Widerspiel zurück. Ja, ein Widerspiel ist ja ein viel besseres Medium eigentlich als ein Buch. Es ist ein viel cooleres Medium als ein Buch. Viel grösserer Widerspielwert eigentlich. So Highscore knacken, das ist in der Bibel halt schwer. Ja. Ja. Irgendeinen Lieferservice, den du gerne benutzt oder so? Ich habe mir drei Fragen aufgeschrieben. Ich bin gerade bei Foodora. Ah. Kennst du Foodora? Ich kenne nur Fedora.
Den Hut.
Ach so, davon abgeleitet.
Foodora.
Ah, okay.
Das ist ein ganz besonderer Liefer-Service, und zwar ist der nicht irgendein, ich werde auch von dem bezahlt.
Liefert nicht an Frauen.
Das ist ja, das ist ja.
Der hat nicht eine eigene Küche irgendwie so, wie Joey's Pizza, wo du irgendwie, keine Ahnung, verrottete Krussen kriegst, irgendwie so, sondern die gehen wirklich zu.
Also, kennst du die fette Kuh?
Ja.
Vielen Dank. irgendwie so, wie Joey's Pizza, wo du irgendwie, keine Ahnung, verrottete Krussen kriegst, irgendwie so, sondern die gehen wirklich zu, also kennst du die fette Kuh? Ja. Mit Foodora kannst du bei der fetten Kuh bestellen und die fahren für dich zur fetten Kuh und nehmen dir den Burger mit und bringen den Qual. Also du kannst ja wirklich bei deinem Lieblingsrestaurant bestellen und die Breettes fette Kuh nicht, es ist dann Südstadt Burger, für die Champions League reicht League reicht es halt dann nicht immer. Und ja, da hat das ganz gut funktioniert. Deswegen, da bestelle ich Säge. Habe ich heute wieder bestellt, ich habe mir ein Burrito kommen lassen. Geil. Ich gebe die Pointe an, ich meine, die liegt so offen da, die muss man eigentlich nur noch reinmachen, da habe ich kein Problem da. Wir sind ja auch gerade in so einer Findungsphase, also dieser dieser Podcast Ganz kurze Frage, hast du schon mal einen Podcast von uns gehört eigentlich? Hast du es schon mal gehört? Nein, nein. Also wir sind ein sehr weirder Podcast, würde ich uns einigen. Wir sind die ganze Zeit nur am Es ist unsympathisch, auch ganz, in seinen eigenen Podcast vorzustellen, wir sind ein bisschen anders als die anderen, du hast es ja schon gemerkt, wir sind ein bisschen crazy, aber das ist halt nur ein bisschen verrückt. Also mach da einfach mit, ja, du kommst da ganz einfach rein, es ist überhaupt kein Problem, leh nicht einfach zurück. Ja, hau raus, wie willst du uns denn beschreiben? Was wolltest du gerade, wo wolltest du gerade ein Gespräch führen? Ich finde, sich selbst beschreiben geht einfach immer schief. Das ist eine dieser Sätze wie, ich bin kein Nazi, aber, ist genauso ein Satz wie, ich bin ein Mensch der. Danach kommt einfach nur Schwachsinn.
Schwierig. Labeln, sich selbst labeln ist immer schwierig.
Man sollte das machen, was man macht, aus vollster Überzeugung und das Labeln den anderen überlassen.
Man sollte nicht über sich selbst reden. Ich bin ein Mensch, ich würde mich selber als Filmschaffender bezeichnen.
Ja.
So.
Als Content Creator.
Ja.
Deswegen ist die Werbung von Christian Ulm ja auch so wahnsinnig uncool, wie er, hast du die Werbung gesehen? Nein, mit Unity Media, wo er irgendwie, ich mache Filme. Ja genau, wo er sagt, ich mache Filme und das ist ja, eigentlich ist es ja kein richtiger Job und ich mache das ja nur aus. Ja gut, aber ich sag mal so, wenn da ein sechsstelliger Betrag im Raum steht, dann verlierst du die Erde recht schnell, glaube ich. Ja, aber das ist doch eine sehr interessante Diskrepanz, eigentlich von so Leuten, wo man sagt, die sind eigentlich relativ cool. Erfurthin ist ein wahnsinniger Christian-Ulm-Fan. Das ist so mein Arm, wo ich dich mit ins Gespräch holen will. Danke, das ist nett. Ja, aber das ist ja wirklich uncool. Das ist ja die Frage, wie geht man denn für Geld in dem Sinne, wie man seine Kunst verkauft. Sehr gute Frage. Hast du noch Antwortmöglichkeiten aufgeschrieben oder wo soll das jetzt hinführen? A, sehr weit. Bin ich nah genug dran am Mikrofon? Nein, ich glaube, das hat mir jetzt alles nicht gehört, was du bis jetzt gesagt hast. Also falls ihr da im Hintergrund so ein Muscheln gehört hat. Das war Maxi Stettenmauer, vielen Dank, dass er da war. Fantastisch, dass er da war. Helmut Zerlet! Vielen Dank, vielen Dank. Warst du mal im Studio, hast du eine Aufzeichnung von Harald Schmidt angeguckt? Nee. Nie. Interessiert dich gar nicht? Ich fand ihn immer gut, aber es hat mich dann doch nicht so stark interessiert, dass ich da live hingehe. Okay. Deswegen. Ich habe mir gerne mal Letterman angeguckt, aber den habe ich leider verpeilt. Aber hast du schon mal amerikanische Letterman angeguckt, oder? Ne, leider gar nicht. Das ist echt so eine Sache, das würde ich gerne immer machen. Ja, aber wen gibt es denn jetzt noch für dich da? Ja, gut, ich bin sehr gespannt, was Stephen Colbert jetzt machen wird, da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Ich fand, leider auch Craig Ferguson fand ich immer genial, jetzt den neuen James Corden oder wie er heisst, der finde ich total langweilig, der interessiert mich gar nicht, weil alle jetzt mittlerweile so im Happy-Happy-Joy-Joy-Modus sind, weil das ist momentan was in unserer postmodernen Zeit am besten funktioniert, keine Kanten, keine Gefahr, alles ist toll, alle haben keine Probleme und das interessiert mich jetzt nicht so. Hast du denn Kanten und Probleme? Bitte? Hast du denn Kanten und Probleme? Ob ich Kanten und Probleme habe, das ist jetzt... Das ist eine alte Interviewregel, immer wenn der Gast irgendwas kritisiert, immer sofort hinterfragen, hast du das denn? Genau, klar, klar, das ist so... Frank-Elzner-Moderation. Die Frank-Elzner-Moderation schlug, ja. Das ist so die Frank-Elzner-Masterclass. Ja. Entschuldigung. Ja, sorry. So viel Zeit muss sein. Entschuldigung, da sind doch schon ganz grosse Talente rausgekommen, wie... Stefan Titzel. Dieser Dings hier, wie heißt der noch? Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Daniel Aminati. Wirklich? Ich glaube, Frank Elstner ist der einzige, wirklich, der hat den Frank Elstner Masterclass als Volker rausgegangen. Das stimmt, ja. Komm mal hin. Nee, also das ist so jetzt der Moment, wo ich vermenschlicht werde, ist das so der Moment jetzt, wo du... Das kommt jetzt ganz auf dich. Wir holen jetzt diesen Mythos, diesen Mythos Maxi Stettenbauer holen wir jetzt runter auf den Mythos. Diesen Mythos, diesen Stand-up-Comedy-Schleim Schleim ist rum, Gott der da, sagen wir mal, die die Comedy-Szene deutschlandweit anführt. Ach ja, okay. Das war ja nicht nur geschleimt, das war auch gelogen. Das habe ich gelogen, das ist einfach falsch, du hast seinen Namen falsch ausgesprochen. Das war einfach falsch. Du bist ja eigentlich Luke-Morridge. Ich habe letztens ein fettes Kind auf dem Fahrrad gesehen und ich dachte mir, das ist doch eigentlich... Und dann hast du gemerkt, dass du in den Spiegel guckst. Ohaha! Nicht schlecht. Und da dachte ich mir, das ist doch eigentlich eine ganz schöne Metapher fürs Leben eigentlich. Sind wir nicht alle nur ein fettes Kind auf einem Fahrrad? Ich meine, das Fahrrad ändert sich über die Zeit und Zeit. Als Kind sitzt man auf einem Fahrrad, später sitzt man dann auf einer Beziehung oder finanzielle Probleme oder auf einem Beruf. Aber im Endeffekt ist man ein fettes schwitzendes Kind auf einem Fahrrad am Strassenrand, das jederzeit von einem Lkw überrollt werden könnte.
Für Außenstehende sieht es lustig aus, aber... Was ist die Lehre, was ist denn die Lehre daraus aus dieser Metapher? Nein, die Metapher brauchen wir nicht unbedingt in Lehre haben, es ist einfach ein schönes Bild, dass ich mir gedacht habe, ich sehe mich in diesem Kind wieder. Ja, das denke ich mir, dass du dich da wieder siehst, denke ich mir. Ähm, nein, das tut mir leid, dass ich da jetzt…
Wir sind immer so, bei Gästen haben wir immer so das Problem, dass wir uns selber immer
in den Rücken fahren, aber das ist okay, das ist okay. Ihr seht das auch wie ein Wettbewerb. Natürlich, auf jeden Fall. Ihr seht das auch, jeder will lustiger sein als der andere. Wir sind auch so kaputt, dass wir wirklich auch kontinuierlich Gags raushauen wollen, auch bewahrten, auch eben, als wir dich begrüßt haben und gemerkt. Es ist mega awkward für Leute, die uns zum ersten Mal begegnen, meistens, glauben wir immer, weil wir halt, weil wir halt kontinuierlich Gags raushauen wollen, auch bewahrten, auch eben als wir dich begrüsst haben und gemerkt, dass es mega awkward für Leute ist, die uns im ersten Mal begegnen, meistens, glauben wir immer, weil wir halt kontinuendlich Gags raushauen wollen. Weil wir halt nichts anderes gelernt haben, weil wir nicht wissen, wie wir mit Menschen umgehen können, außer halt versuchen, zu sein. Auf so einer Gag-Ebene, wir sind sehr ehrlich in der Hinsicht. Ja, weil wir halt einfach ein fettes Kind auf dem Fahrrad sind. Ihr beide seid ein Kind. Das einzige Fahrrad, das wir haben, ist Humor. Wir sind zwei fette Kinder auf einem Tandem des Lebens. Aus diesem Fahrrad, ja, aus dem Fahrrad oder so mit, ja, da nehmen wir schon die beste Metafeln tatsächlich, da fällt mir nichts Besseres ein, muss ich dir geben. Aber tatsächlich, Humor ist unser Fahrrad und wir schwitzen und treten, aber wir kommen nicht wirklich voran. Aber es ist das beste Fahrrad, das wir haben. Und jetzt ist die Frage, hätte da die Mutter nicht mal gucken können, dass man vielleicht früher die Stutzräder hätte abnehmen sollen? Wo sind die Schwimmflügel? Warum hat das fette Kind eigentlich keinen Helm auf? Das sind dann die Fragen, die sich mir stellen. Also du sehnst dich nach Zuneigung? Ich seh mich nach Zuneigung, Liebe und Nähe und Intimität. Und Fahrrad. Und das gibt es eigentlich viel einfach nur mit dem Fahrrad, mit dem Fahrrad wurde geklaut. Und ich hatte jetzt eine Zeit lang kein Internet. Und das ist echt keine schöne Zeit. Ja gut, jetzt hast du das Bild des fetten Kindes vollends angenommen. Weil man einfach merkt, dass es manche Teppiche in seinem Leben gibt, die, wenn sie weg sind, einfach mal verloren ist. Ich habe überhaupt nichts auf meinem Rechner. Alle Musik, die ich höre, alle Filme, die ich schaue, alles ist Internet. Und ich saß dann zu Hause und wollte Musik hören und hatte, weil ich für ein Video was bearbeitet hatte, hatte ich einmal so einen einstündigen Loop von karibischer Musik,
so karibische Hintergrundmusik, und dann saß ich da in meinem Keller, habe ein Gelbwurstbrot gegessen und habe nur karibische Musik gehört, einfach ein ganzes Wochenende lang, weil ich nichts anderes hatte als diesen ständigen Loop karibischer Musik. Und da habe ich mir auch gedacht, dafür war ich auf der Frank-Elsa-Masterclass, dafür habe ich 19 Jahre lang studiert, was soll das? Ich merke schon die böhmermensche ironisch gegen alles haltung zieht sich durch das komplette gebäude kann das sein absolut das ist interessant das problem ist an an so einer nein nein nein also nö so weit kenne ich jetzt der satz war nur der pointe geschulden kenne ich kenne ich also so weit so weit kenne ich euch beide halt Witz hat er schon jeden beleidigt. Deswegen kann ich... Da sind Fakten auch egal. Würde ich auch nicht so unterschreiben. Wen würdest du niemals beleidigen? Das ist die falsche Frage. Die Frage ist... Was ist die richtige Frage? Die richtige Frage ist... Die richtige Frage ist, wie weit würdest du für einen Gag gehen? Ja, und? Wie weit würdest du für einen Gag gehen? Ich weiss nicht, ich weiss nicht, das wäre doch mal eine interessante Frage. Ganz kurz, ich hatte heute eine Tweet-Idee und habe sie nicht gemacht. Ja, ich habe einen Holocaust-Gag. Und der Tweet war, also jetzt ganz kurz, deine instinktive, spontane Reaktion. Ja. Arbeit macht Bauch frei. Ja. Ist das was für dich, kannst du damit was anfangen oder ist das für dich No-Go? Arbeit macht Bauch frei, hm, jetzt fehlt mir jetzt der Kontext. Kennst du diese Kleidungsstücke, wo man den Bauch noch so sieht? Ja, aber je mehr ich arbeite, umso nur weil ich mehr arbeite, wird der Bauch nicht freier. Ja, aber... Und auch das Kleidungsstück wird auch nicht. Und das Problem ist, sobald du ansetzen musst... Ja, ich weiss, aber die Anspielung auf das, was über dem KZ stand, alleine reicht nicht. Ah, okay, so, jetzt kommen wir natürlich ein ganzes Problem. Aber jetzt kommen wir doch mal zu der, wie tief es muss kommend sein. Keine Ahnung, es muss erst mal lustig sein. Aber glaubst du, wenn er mir einen One-Liner bringt und ich muss nicht lachen, dann fehlt was. Okay, du bist aber auch ein zynisches Arschloch, muss man halt auch dazu sagen. Du werdest jetzt in keiner Situation gelacht, oder doch? Weiß ich nicht. Also ich meine, erst mal Arbeit macht Bauch frei. Das ist einfach mal gut formuliert so, und es ist ja auch von gut geschrieben so, aber ich sehe den Gag nicht. Dankeschön. Ich sehe den Gag nicht. Naja, also ganz kurz, wir erklären uns, wir versuchen ja auch Komite zu analysieren, und wir erklären uns die Funktion eines Gags als L-Form. Du baust eine gewisse Strasse auf, baust eine Erwartung auf, das Publikum denkt, es geht in eine gewisse Richtung weiter. So muss man sich mit so einer Erklärmusik denken. Und jetzt sagst du Arbeit macht und jeder denkt frei und ich sag bauchfrei. Und das plötzlich diese beiden Bilder, einmal furchtbar schlimm Nationalsozialismus und einmal 14-jähriges Mädchen bauchfrei mit kurzem Rock vorm Verfassungsgericht. das sind halt die zwei Bilder, die dann plötzlich zusammenkommen, wo man sagt, meine Herren,
wirklich dafür habe ich acht Euro ausgegeben für den Quatsch Comedy Club.
Das ist halt so der Gedankengang.
Okay.
Reicht dir nicht, ne? Also eine Überraschung zum Ende.
Nein, ich brauche keinen Unterbau.
Es ist total simpel, es ist subjektiv.
Und ich wüsste nicht, wie ich reagiert hätte, hätte ich jetzt den Tweet von dir gelesen. Das weiss ich nicht. Du hast ihn gemeldet. Ich weiss nur, wie du ihn mir jetzt gebracht hast, mit einer leichten Unsicherheit usw. Und dann kann ich mir, deswegen, weil jetzt spielt ja alles mit, jetzt spielt ja der komplette Kontext der Situation mit. Hätte ich den Tweet jetzt so einfach nur gelesen, dann weiß ich nicht, wie ich reagiert hätte. Deswegen, es ist einfach subjektiv. Du kannst den Gag jetzt tweeten und er könnte durch die Decke gehen oder auch nicht, ich weiß es nicht. Egal wie lange jemand in der Comedy unterwegs ist, vielleicht kann er auf mehr Erfahrungswerte zurückblicken als du, aber was wirklich witzig ist, weiss niemand so genau. Das ist meine Erfahrung. Aber wie machst du dann, also hast du dann nicht, als du zum ersten Mal Material hattest für Stand-Up, wie hast du denn ein bisschen da rangegangen? Also du hast ja dann wahrscheinlich auch schon damals gedacht, okay, keine Ahnung, wie das ankommt, ich habe keinen Plan, ich habe irgendwas geschrieben, ich finde das lustig, subjektiv, aber das kann jeder andere, kann es furchtbar finden. Und Und wie war es denn? Furchtbar war es, natürlich war es furchtbar. Und wo kommt man dann, also sind es nur Erfahrungswerte, die du dich berufst? Mittlerweile, wenn du mal ein neues Material machst? Ich war die ersten, das ist jetzt natürlich auch wieder, wenn man einen Gag machen will, kann man jetzt gerne einen machen, aber die ersten drei Jahre war ich wirklich ein ziemlich schlechter Stand-Up-Comedian. Und jetzt sagen wir, das ist nur die ersten drei Jahre. Aber kannst du den nochmal kurz mitgeschreiben? Ich habe da auch nicht so, also ich mache da keine Illusionen draus. Bis man wirklich gut ist in Stand-Up, zumindest war es bei mir so, es gibt Leute, die haben dann einfach gottgegebenes Talent und sind dann einfach total krass vom ersten Moment an. Wir werden gleich noch zurückkommen. Ich habe noch keinen getroffen, aber die gibt es sicherlich. Aber bei mir hat es echt lange gedauert, bis ich so für mich das Gefühl hatte, so okay, jetzt ist es einigermassen okay. Glaubst du, ich meine, jeder hat ja seinen eigenen Stil und seine eigenen Sachen, die er lustig findet. Aber glaubst du, dir würde es leichter fallen, auf der Bühne Lacher zu bekommen, wenn du von diesem Stil abweichen kannst? Also glaubst du nicht, es gibt da ein gewisses Handwerk dahinter, dass du sagst, mit gewissen Themen, mit gewissen Pointen, mit gewissen Strukturen kriege ich Lacher, egal ob ich jetzt wirklich lustig finde oder nicht? Oder anders, du fragst, das Mario-Barth-Problem, will er das machen, was er da gerade macht? Oder macht er einfach, dass es funktioniert? Ist es dieses E und U-Pro dieses E und U-Problem? Keine Ahnung, da müsstet ihr ihn mal einladen. Ich weiss nicht, was Mario Barth sich so denkt. Es ist natürlich so, dass es beim Publikum eine gewisse Konditionierung gibt, jetzt nach 20 Jahren Comedy und 100.000 Jahren Kabarett irgendwie, dass gewisse Sachen einfach immer funktionieren werden, dass es eine Rhythmik gibt, die beim Publikum immer angesprochen wird. Aber was ist denn das Ziel? Willst du ein Künstler sein oder willst du eine Coverband sein? Aber hattest du schon mal einen Gag im Programm, den du selber jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig gut fandest, der aber wahnsinnig gut beim Publikum ankam? Oder deckt sich deine Einschätzung der Gags immer mit der Reaktion des Publikums?
Also ich versuche, meine Gags nie zu isolieren und einzeln zu bewerten, sondern ich versuche immer zu gucken, habe ich noch Bock auf das Thema generell. Das heißt, wenn ich keine Lust mehr auf meine Batman-Nummer habe, dann spiele ich die Batman-Nummer nicht mehr. Aber es gab Zeiten, wo ich zum Beispiel irgendwie einen guten Schlussgag brauche, einen starken Closer, und dann habe ich halt, und ich hatte nur einen, ich hatte nur einen Closer, der wirklich gut war, der Rest war nur Dreck, ja, und wenn du dann immer, das Problem ist, wenn du dann diesen Closer machst, weil du ihn machen musst, weil du einfach nichts anderes hast, ist es eigentlich fast immer besser, dass du einfach dein Set vorher aufhörst und nicht etwas machst, auf das du keinen Bock mehr hast.
Das heißt, du schreibst dein Standardprogramm dann quasi auch so, dass du dir die Themen raussuchst, wo du halt Maximum an Energie bockst.
Nein, ich schreibe überhaupt gar nicht.
Du lässt schreiben.
Ich lasse auch nicht schreiben.
Ich gehe so durch den Tag und gucke, was da so anspringt und dann setze ich mich jeden Tag eine Stunde hin und mache mir kleinere Notizen, Blickwinkel, Ideen, Herangehensweisen, Dinge, die mich eventuell interessieren könnten. Und dann, wenn irgendwie eine Sache sich weit genug in meinem Kopf entwickelt hat, weil ich gehe ja auch schwanger dann mit den Sachen und wälze sie immer wieder in meinem Kopf umher. Und wenn ich dann das Gefühl habe, okay, jetzt probiere ich es
mal aus, dann probiere ich es einfach auf der Bühne aus. Und manchmal funktioniert es okay,
manchmal funktioniert es gar nicht, manchmal funktioniert es richtig gut. Also es ist ganz
schwer, ich kann da keine allgemeine Regel für finden.
Okay, ja, ich habe das letzte Mal
in der letzten Folge Podcast UFO
angekündigt, weil wir ja schon,
also wir sind ja beide, sag ich mal, Comedy-interessiert
und wir haben auch beide Bock, irgendwie
langfristig auch mal Stand-Up auszuprobieren und
wir schreiben schon ein bisschen hier und da was,
um mal Stand-Up auszuprobieren und ich habe letztes Folge
gesagt, ich nehme deinen Besuch zum
Anlass, einfach mal
ähm, ja, ein Stand-Up zu schreiben, einfach mal fünf Minuten und den einfach mal rauszuhauen, einfach damit ich mal einen Termin habe, damit ich eine Deadline habe, damit ich mal irgendwie den ersten Schritt mache, weil ich glaube, der erste Schritt ist sehr schwer. Und ja, nee, also du lernst es am meisten, wenn du es auf einer Bühne machst. Mein Feedback in der Situation bringt dir gar nichts. Okay, aber es ist natürlich auch relativ lustig, wenn er versagt. Also auch in dieser kleinen Gruppe, es ist schon ein bisschen auch Comedy-Potential, jetzt für den Hörer den gemeinen Podcast-Projektor zu haben. Ja, aber es würde nur darin resultieren, dass einer dumm dasteht. Aus Scham würde es totalisieren. So, ja. Okay, aber er würde es ja selber, ich weiß es nicht. Nee, aber du hast ja selber gesagt, man muss ja am Anfang dumm dastehen. Du standest am Anfang auch dumm da, oder nicht? Ich meine, du darfst ja keine Angst davor haben, dumm dazustehen. Das ist klar, aber ich finde, man sollte es einfach auf der Bühne machen, weil Stand-up ist eine Bühnenkunstform so, und jetzt im Zwiegespräch, das ist ein komplett anderer Kontext, und das ist so, das ist wie wenn du einem Fussballer sagst, mach doch, versuch doch mal mit Handball, oder so. Das ist so, du nimmst etwas und ziehst es aus seinem Element raus. Okay. Gut. Er geht aber seiner Verteidigung her, er bin nicht was vorbereitet,, weil es da draußen irgendwelche Beschwerden ist. Es ist auch nicht so wahnsinnig unglaublich gut geworden. Ich habe ein bisschen was zusammengeschrieben, aber ich wollte was machen. Du könntest ja gleich mal so ein Gespräch zwischendurch einfach mal raushauen, so ein paar Sachen. Ne, das ist ja eben gerade der Unterschied. Ich finde, das ist schon ein starker Unterschied, ob man, weil ich meine, das ist ja das Problem an Stand-Up, dass du wirklich mit einem, oh jetzt wird's lustig, Ding auf die Bühne gehst. Und das ist ja was ganz anderes, als wenn du im Gespräch irgendwie Gags einbauen lässt, wo jeder Gag schon mal etwas Positives ist, weil überhaupt was Lustiges ist, wohingegen auf der Bühne wird es genau umgedreht, da ist alles, was nicht lustig ist, negativ. Und deswegen ist es eine ganz andere Situation. Und es ist auch, also ich meine, du wirst ja wahrscheinlich, also ich meine, kennst du das auch, dass du als professioneller Stand-Up-Kommunist auf die Bühne gehst und Gags machst? Das ist schon sein Stand-Up-Programm. Nein, nein, nein, und dir dann im Gespräch mit anderen Leuten denkst, hey, der hat jetzt gerade spontan aus dem Nichts einen besseren Gag rausgehauen als ich auf der Bühne. Nein. Ist das nicht unfair? Nee, passiert das nicht? Nein. Er umgibt sich nur mit wahnsinnig unlustigen Menschen. Weil die Gesprächssituation eine völlig andere ist als die Bühnensituation. Da werden in dir als Mensch völlig andere Essenzen frei. Du bist ja in einem komplett anderen Modus. Auf der Bühne bist du im anderen Universum einfach total. Also wenn du hier in der Gruppe, ist es oft so, dass der Humor, der in einer Gruppe entsteht, oft referenziell ist. Also es funktioniert dann halt auch nur bei den Leuten, die wirklich da waren in der Gruppe, weil es sich oft auf etwas bezieht, was innerhalb der Gruppe irgendwie stattfindet oder weil man einander vertraut ist. Als Stand-Up-Comedian gehst du auf die Bühne hoch vor Menschen, die dich im Zweifel in neun von zehn Fällen noch nie gesehen haben, keine Ahnung, wer du bist, und du musst es schaffen, innerhalb von 15 bis 20 Sekunden einen Rapport herzustellen, damit die Leute wissen, wer du bist, was du machst und damit die sich mit dir irgendwie wohlfühlen und damit dir irgendwas anfangen können, was ja in so einem Gespräch wie hier nicht so wirklich gegeben ist. So, hier hat man Zeit, hier kann man sich mal hinsetzen, ein Glas Wasser trinken und so, und hier hat man wirklich die Zeit, jemanden kennenzulernen und wirklich sich irgendwie darauf einzulassen. Aber hilft dir diese, oh jetzt wird's lustig, Einstellung des Publikums, hilft dir die eher, weil das Publikum eher bereit ist zu lachen, oder ist es eher ein Druck, dass du sozusagen deliveren musst und es hemmt dich eher. Also ist Ist es einfacher, auf der Bühne Lacher zu holen? Nein. Oder es ist schwerer? Ich weiß, das ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Also wenn man es irgendwie eine Zeit lang effektiv macht, fragt man sich das nicht mehr. Das ist wie Autofahren. Du steigst dann, irgendwann kommt ein Punkt, wo du es so oft gemacht hast und so oft neue Nummern geschrieben hast und auch so viel falsch gemacht hast, dass du einfach für dich ein Gefühl hast, so, okay, ich habe jetzt nicht das Ende, das komplett alles verstanden, aber ich habe jetzt für mich einfach eine Bühnensicherheit über 700 oder 1000 Sets erspielt, wo du halt dann einfach mit einem anderen, mit viel Hintergrundwissen auch hochgehst und verstehst so, okay, das macht mich als Comedian aus. Und damit kannst du dann einen Kontakt mit dem Publikum aufbauen. Genauso ist es beim Autofahren. Die ersten paar Mal bist du halt echt noch ein bisschen nervös, du verschaltest dich, machst ein paar Fehler, aber irgendwann steigst du einfach ein und fährst los, du denkst nicht mehr gross drüber nach. So ein Louis C. C. zum Beispiel, den wir hier sehr oft zitieren, ein bisschen zu oft vielleicht, der hat ja zum Beispiel, fängt er seine Shows manchmal damit an, um zu sagen, ja gut, hier sind jetzt 2000 Leute, statistisch gesehen stirbt einer von euch im nächsten Jahr und sagt dann, okay, sorry, ich weiss nicht wirklich, wie ich mit Shows beginnen soll. Einfach weil er, das ist ein guter Gag, zum einen, und zum zweiten, weiss ich, glaub, traue ich ihm aber sogar, dass er wirklich nicht weiss, wie man mit Shows beginnen soll, weil die Situation einfach ruiert ist. Du kannst nicht, weil es gibt ja wirklich keinen wirklichen Grund dafür, dass er zu einem Publikum spricht und Witze erzählt. Das ist ja ein ganz perfider Grund, so ein Unterhaltungswille von den Leuten, die da unten sitzen. Und eigentlich ist es, wenn man sich das bewusst macht, doch wahnsinnig absurd eigentlich auch. Ja gut, dann gibt es Leute, die irgendwie aus Sportmatten Pommes formen und das im Museum Ludwig ausstellen und das als grosse Kunst gilt. Ja klar, wenn man sich bewusst macht, dieser Anfang, dieser erste Gag ist doch eigentlich mega schwer. Also hast du das, also ich verstehe das nicht. Ja klar ist der schwer, der erste Gag definiert deinen Stammpunkt gegenüber dem Publikum, dieser erste Gag ist doch eigentlich mega schwer. Also, oder hast du das, also ich verstehe das nicht. Ja, klar ist der schwer. Der erste Gag definiert deinen Stammpunkt gegenüber dem Publikum. Der erste Gag entscheidet, wie wird das Set laufen? So, es gibt ganz wenige Comedians, die über die Spielstärke verfügen, dass sie nach dem ersten verschissenen Gag die Leute dann nochmal holen. Also würdest du dann, würdest du jemals dich für einen Gag verkaufen? Also würdest du wirklich immer Gags raushauen irgendwann, die nur in das Publikum gefallen, wo du weißt, die funktionieren, aber und die bringen Cash, aber die sind für mich als Kunstform vielleicht eigentlich nicht so akzeptabel eigentlich. Das Krasse an Stand-Up ist ja, dass du dich nur sehr bedingt in die künstlerische Ebene vorwagen kannst, denn du bist immer ein bisschen an die Akzeptanz des Publikums gebunden. Du kannst da nicht wirklich, du kannst jetzt nicht auf einmal krasse Callbacks über Silver Age in den DC Comics machen oder so, weil du halt dann nicht das Wissen im Publikum hast, um da, selbst ich habe mir das gerade einfach aus dem Arsch gezogen, ich habe auch keine Ahnung, was da passiert ist. Ich hätte es mir glaubt, das hat mich wahnsinnig übersorgt. Aber die Aufgabe ist halt, ich arbeite gerade an so einem Batman-Bit, wo ich halt darüber erzähle, dass Batman der einzige Superheld ist im DC-Universum, der keine Superkräfte hat. Und arbeite halt da was aus. Und die Aufgabe ist halt, dass du die Idee, die du hast, dass du die so aufschlüsselst und so erklärst und so aufbaust, dass selbst jemand, der Batman nicht kennt, weiss, was lustig an dieser Situation ist. So bin ich eigentlich immer vorgegangen. Oder Game of Thrones hast du jetzt in deinem. Oder Game of Thrones zum Beispiel, ne? Also die Leute müssen Game of Thrones nicht gesehen haben, die Leute müssen das Thema, über das du sprichst, nicht hundert Prozent durchdrungen haben, sie müssen nur verstehen, was dich dran flasht. Du musst zeigen, wie du fühlst, wie du denkst, was deine, was deine Halt ist. Du setzt ihm quasi deine Brille auf. Ja, also es hört sich so klassisch auf, aber du musst die irgendwie in deine Welt holen. Entschuldigung, ich habe gerade gerülpst. Das ist so, dann machen wir immer so. Ich meine, du bist ja so ein bisschen der exzentrische Exot eigentlich in der Situation. Das ist ja so ein bisschen das Sheldon-Cooper-Prinzip irgendwie, dass der halt komplett drin ist in seiner Welt und deswegen irgendwie liebenswürdig, weil man natürlich auch als Zuschauer diese Leidenschaft gerne sieht irgendwie, dass er komplett für irgendwas lebt. weil viele Leute vielleicht diese Leidenschaft selber nicht haben und deswegen Leute gerne anschauen wollen, die diese Leidenschaft haben und wenn du sagst, ich finde es total geil, wie Game of Thrones hier und da oder wie du dich über die kleinsten Details aufregen kannst, einfach dieses in der Welt stehen, diese Welt mit einem offenen Auge und mit einem Enthusiasmus zu sehen, die das Publikum vielleicht nicht hat irgendwie. Ja, das istisch Maxi, dass dem auffällt, dass man irgendwie den Rewe durchs Fenster schauen kann, aber trotzdem nicht hingeht, sondern sich liefern lässt und sowas. Das erleben viele Leute, aber die haben eben nicht diese exotische Aussenseitsicht. Es ist ja dann letztlich eigentlich eine Weltsicht, die man da verkauft. Es ist immer in irgendeiner Form. Aber deswegen diese Frage, würdest du Gags machen? Alter, ich war schon mal so pleite. So, jetzt kommen wir auf den Punkt. Jetzt kommen wir auf den Kern Kohle. Also deswegen, ich finde es ganz schwierig, so moralische, absolute Statements irgendwie zu fällen, finde ich immer schwierig.
Aber das wollen wir hören.
Würde ich das momentan machen? Eher nicht.
Habe ich das vor drei Jahren mal gemacht, habe ich vor vier, fünf Jahren, als ich keine Kohle hatte, mal Werbung für Nivea gemacht?
Ja, habe ich gemacht, weil es da richtig viel Geld gab.
Weißt du, ich meine, Bill Hicks hat ja mal gesagt, sobald du Werbung machst, bist du als Künstler nicht mehr glaubwürdig. Wo ist er jetzt? Weiß ich nicht. Leider, leider tot. Fettnerpilflur. Ich weiß, dass er tot ist. Ja, gut, ich meine auch. Mein Gott, Alter. Aber, weißt du, ich finde das echt schwierig, das ist ein ziemlich harter Markt, so. Also ich meine, wo du dich halt echt durchkämpfen musst und dass du da mit einer eigenen authentischen Stimme in irgendeiner Form überleben kannst, ist schon selten genug so. Und deswegen,
weiß ich nicht, ich finde das irgendwie,
finde ich schwierig sowas.
Ja, aber ich meine, es ist ja wahrscheinlich auch einfach schön, wenn Leute über deine Gags lachen.
So ein Abend macht dir wahrscheinlich wesentlich mehr Spaß.
Wenn die Leute einfach lachen und du dich gut fühlst,
das ist ja letztendlich auch irgendwo ein Job.
Und du machst es halt jeden Abend und gehst hin.
Und der Job ist umso geniessbarer, wenn du
halt tatsächlich Rückmeldung bekommst.
Aber ich gehe in diesem Handwerk voll auf. Also das ist so, alle Potenziale, die ich so habe, gehen da halt auf. Du hast eine Idee, du hast eine Beobachtung und denkst also, okay, wie verklausuliere ich das jetzt? Wie baue ich das auf, wie gehe ich da hin? Und dann fällt dir dieser eine Satz ein, oder du hast schon den Satz, aber er ist noch nicht prägnant genug, er ist noch nicht präzise genug, er ist noch nicht an der richtigen Stelle, du hast noch nicht die richtige Betonung. Es ist, also ich finde Stand-up, auch wenn es hier in Deutschland sehr verrufen ist und coole Leute, wie die hier arbeiten, das auch immer so ein bisschen herablassend betrachten, ich selber finde es eine wahnsinnig grandiose, unfassbar intelligente und schwierige Kunstform, die nur ganz wenige echte Meister haben. Es gibt viele Leute, die es machen, aber das sind oft Leute, die sich von einem Handwerksdübel zum nächsten schwingen und nicht wirklich etwas damit sagen. Es gibt ja nur ganz wenige Stand-Upper, die wirklich Stand-Up als Handwerk nutzen, um ihre Idee auszudrücken. Wie es Musiker machen, wie es Bob Dylan macht mit seiner Musik oder wie es halt Künstler machen, die halt während in Deutschland der Comedian, ich bin sofort fertig. Ja, ich habe schon laut eingeatmet damit, weil sie nicht reden. Während in Deutschland der Comedian oft zu einem Dienstleister verkommt.
Aber würdest du sagen, dass die deutsche Comedy-Szene zu Recht so verrufen ist oder in den Verruf geraten ist?
Also wie stehst du zu deutschen Comedy-Szenen allgemein?
Wir haben beide so das Gefühl, dass du schon irgendwie so ein bisschen so eine eigene Rolle einnimmst.
Du machst das, was du cool findest und das kauft man dir ab, aber bei anderen halt nicht.
Und deswegen, also vielleicht sind die deswegen da vom Standing her, wo sie jetzt sind, aber wie siehst du das da, wie siehst du dich selber so in Deutschland? Also in dieser Frage schwingen ja mehrere Fragen mit. Das ist ja nicht nur eine Sache. Also wie sehe ich die deutsche Comedy-Szene?
Ich finde es ein bisschen oft klischeebehaftet, was aber oft einfach damit zu tun hat, weil es das Publikum auch sehr oft gutiert. Ist halt oftmals so das Problem. Deswegen und weil jetzt über 20 Jahre lang die gleichen Mechanismen, die gleichen Themen, die gleichen Gesichter auch immer
wieder in den Vordergrund geschoben werden,
hat sich natürlich ein
Grossteil, es gibt immer noch
eine grosse Masse, die das natürlich verfolgt
und so, aber
ganz viele Leute, vor allem in meinem
Alter, sich der Comedy einfach abgewendet
haben, weil es da nichts mehr gibt,
was sie da irgendwie triggert, weil ihnen das irgendwie, weil da nichts mehr ist, weil es ihnen irgendwie fehlt. Die Verbindung zur Realität fehlt ihnen da so ein bisschen. Denn man muss ja auch sagen, dass die Comedy-Szene für sich ein hermetisch abgeriegelter Bereich ist. Es ist eine Blase. Gags funktionieren nur, weil sie innerhalb der Comedy-Szene abgesprochen sind. Rainer-Kallmund-Gags, Westerwelle-Gags und so weiter, diese ganzen Sachen, die einfach innerhalb dieser Blase so oft wiederholt wurden, dass sie jetzt als Realität innerhalb dieser Blase akzeptiert werden. Ich brauche nur noch, ich meine, es gibt immer noch Kollegen, die Rainer Kalmund als Punchline benutzen und es funktioniert einfach. Ja, aber heisst das auch im Umkehrschluss, dass man das ja kaputt machen kann, dieses Kartenhaus, was da blöderweise seit Jahren, wie das aufgebaut wurde, in dem man einfach das coole Gäste machte. Und das ist dann sehr interessant, wenn man die Struktur, weil das Publikum ist sich dieser Struktur absolut bewusst.
Moment, welcher Struktur, Entschuldigung? Die Struktur, dass der Comedian rauskommt und sich erhebt über die Realität und von oben überall drauf guckt, anstatt wirklich das zu leben, was er sagt. Und ich glaube, da finde ich schon ein, da würde ich mich tatsächlich als anders bezeichnen, auch wenn ich ein Stand-up-Communien natürlich auch bin. Ich gehe raus und versuche wirklich nicht, ich versuche nicht den allwissenden Beobachter zu geben, sondern ich reg mich halt über Kleinigkeiten auf oder versuche einen emotionalen Hook. Wobei ich ja, finde ich, ein bisschen aufpassen muss, weil dieser emotionale Hook halt oft auch manchmal sehr platt ist einfach und sehr einfach. Also ich meine, wenn man Gags über 90er Jahre Serien macht oder halt irgendwie dann die Schlümpfe anspricht oder Biennemaier oder sowas, da hast du das Publikum einfach schon so handzahm, dass sie einfach schon dadurch, dass sie diese nostalgischen Gefühle haben, schon so gut drauf sind. Und dann kommt dann natürlich auch wieder dieser soziale Aspekt,
dass ich lache mit, um zu zeigen, dass ich den Gag verstanden habe.
Ich lache mit, um mich selbst vor mir und vor anderen als Nineties-Kids zu identifizieren.
Da kommen dann all diese ganzen psychologischen Effekte ins Spiel,
dass der Gag an sich eigentlich gar nicht mehr so wichtig ist.
Ja, okay, wir müssen jetzt etwas grundsätzlich in der Diskussion klären.
Reden wir über Stand-Up oder reden wir über Pop? Wir reden über Stand-up. Wir reden über Stand-up, weil was du beschreibst ist Pop. Ja, aber es gibt auch genug Stand-up-Comedians, die sich solcher Thematik bedienen. Ja, klar, natürlich. Aber mein Gott, das ist halt dann so. Das ist ja auch nicht per se schlecht. Ich sage nur, dass es manchmal solche emotionalen Hooks vielleicht zu einfach machen. Nein, nein, nein, nicht emotionalen Hooks beim Publikum, emotionale Hooks bei dir selber. Weißt du, wenn, wenn, ich rede über Game of Thrones, weil es mich wirklich abfuckt, dass die durchgehend vögeln in dieser Folge. Ich verstehe nicht, wie geht das, die haben Krieg, die haben Hungersnöte, wie haben, was haben die für ein Sexualleben, warum sehen die alle so geil aus, weisst du? Und das sind so, das frage ich mich dann wirklich. Ja, stimmt, Arias trage sich wirklich wahnsinnig gut aus. Mein Pädogag muss ich auch in dieser Folge unterbringen. Deswegen, gut, und danke. Und da muss man halt dann gucken, also dann habe ich Nummern, die spiele ich und dann habe ich es halt so oft erzählt, mein Name ist Maximilian Neuer-Alfos-Gstettenbauer, ich habe meine Mutter gefragt, wieso, das habe ich dann so oft erzählt, dass ich es dann echt lange Zeit weglegen muss, bis ich es halt nach einer Zeit wieder authentisch bringen kann, so. Also es ist schon so. Also ich muss ja sagen, was ich an deiner Arbeit ganz speziell auch ganz wichtig finde, auch das ganze, was du drumherum machst, also auch deinen Podcast Städtenteilen, wo du andere Comedians interviewst und so ein bisschen Einblick gibst in das Handwerk und in die Welt hinter. Stand-up-Comedy finde ich ja wahnsinnig wertvoll, weil ich glaube, das Problem der deutschen Stand-up-Comedy-Szene ist nicht allein nur durch die Stand-up-Comedians zu lösen, sondern auch durch die Community ein bisschen. Also es fällt mir immer wieder auf, dass man gerade im Vergleich zu Amerika eine ganz andere Community hat, dass man in Amerika auch gerade diese Comedy-Nerds hat, diese knallharte Hardcore-Comedy-Szene. Absolut. Und unter jedem SNL-Sketch kommentiert so, ah, den und den, den Line habe ich da schon mal gesehen und das ist der Humor von da und super die Performance von dem. Und in dem Thema so tief drin ist und auf so einer krassen Basis versteht, dass man gleich ein ganz anderes Gefühl hat, du hast es hier wirklich mit Experten zu tun, die auch wirklich dann die scharfen Gags belohnen und wirklich die einfachen, oh mein Gott, er redet schon wieder über Rainer Kalm und dann eben bestrafen können. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass diese Nerd-Attitude, diese Comedy-Nerd-Attitude ja gar nicht, noch nicht mal in Deutschland in der Comedy-Szene, also selbst bei denen, die es machen, eigentlich vorhanden ist, was ich schade finde.
Zum Beispiel dieses Gespräch, weißt du vielleicht gar nicht mehr,
aber es hat schon mal stattgefunden. Wir waren auf dem Comedy-Preis
glaube ich vor zwei Jahren oder was war das?
Vor einem Jahr?
Beim Catering war das.
Ja, genau, klar.
Da waren wir zum ersten Mal beide auf dem Comedy-Preis.
Weiß nicht, wir haben zufällig Karten bekommen,
so eine Plus-Eins-Karte oder so.
An dem Abend ist auch die Idee zum Podcast entschieden.
Ja, wir waren mega froh, dass wir mal reingucken konnten, haben uns das aber viel interessanter vorgestellt.
Also wir dachten, das wäre so wahnsinnig lustig. Es muss ja die lustigste Veranstaltung des Jahres sein eigentlich, weil es ist der Comedypreis.
Also die lustigsten Menschen in Deutschland, denkt man da am Catering-Buffet und labern über geile Themen.
Wobei man sagen muss, es gibt nichts Unlustigeres, als über Comedy zu reden.
Ja gut, das merkt ihr vielleicht auch schon
die letzten 40 Minuten.
Aber selbst da hat man das Gefühl,
dass man so ein bisschen, also
so Comedy-News wie wir, so ein bisschen
alleine stehen da. Wir stehen halt am Buffet.
Das ist aber Quatsch, das ist nicht so.
Das ist nicht so. Das habe ich auch
immer gedacht, dass man mit so einer Haltung alleine ist.
Das stimmt aber nicht, weil es ganz, ganz viele Menschen gibt in Deutschland, die das auch denken. Denen fällt auch auf, dass die gucken sich Atze Schröder an und nichts gegen Atze. Der Typ hat es drauf und alles, aber er steht halt für eine Art Humor, die halt jetzt in meiner Welt nicht so stattfindet, nicht so präsent ist einfach. Und die sehen so, okay, warum gibt's immer nur das? Die sich, die das alles angucken, die RTL-Bandbreite abchecken und nichts für sich finden, das aber nicht so formulieren können und nicht wissen, worauf es ist. Und das ist dann der Job von uns, dass wir das thematisieren öffentlich, damit die Leute wissen, wo sie hinkönnen. Und wo können die hin? Ja, niemanden. Es gibt momentan nichts. Deswegen glaube ich, ist das die ganz, ganz grosse Chance. Mich erreichen jeden Tag mehrere E-Mails, manchmal sogar zwei, von Leuten, die selber mit Stand-up anfangen wollen, die irgendwie was machen wollen, aber nicht wissen wie. Das heisst, immer mehr junge Leute haben da Bock drauf und wollen das irgendwie versuchen. Glaubst du, das ist ein neues Phänomen oder war immer schon so? Das ist ein neues Phänomen. Das ist ein absolut neues Phänomen. Ich glaube, es braucht schon Vorbilder. Ich glaube, dass gerade die Vorbildfunktion enorm wichtig ist, um so eine Szene zu bauen. Wenn du halt in Amerika Stand-Up-Comedien werden willst, dann hast du halt die fucking Besten der Welt als Vorbilder. Und natürlich versuchst du auch, um die Fußstapfen zu steigen, in Deutschland halt nicht. Und du hast Leute, die vielleicht gerade mal fünf Jahre älter sind als du und die Stand-Up machen und irgendwo schon im Fernsehen sind oder, es ganz gut läuft sogar irgendwo ein Special haben. Der jüngste Comedian in Deutschland ist vielleicht, wenn du selber 15 bist und du guckst Dieter nur, der halt einfach mal ein erwachsener Mann ist, du hast mit dem nicht so die Identifikation wie mit jemandem, der jetzt vielleicht Mitte 20 ist oder Anfang 20. Das heisst, du denkst so, hey, der ist nicht viel älter als ich und macht das. Cool, ich wusste gar nicht, dass das geht, dass man überhaupt jung Stand-up machen kann. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das geht. Und dann ist das schon wesentlich präsenter in der eigenen Gedankenwelt. Hast du Beta-Tester, also Leute, denen du vorher Gags schickst oder denen du selber vorher, oder du sagst, du schreibst nicht selber, also hast du wahrscheinlich nicht. Es ist so, bei Stand-up ist es so, Stand-up ist eine gesprochene Kunstform. Das heißt, die Leute lachen nicht über den geschriebenen Gag, du verteilst ja deinen Text nicht an die Leute. Das ist interessant, da hat mal jemand gesagt, ich weiß nicht mehr, weil es war... Natasha Leggero war das, hat gesagt, dass Comedy auch auf dem Papier funktionieren muss. Ja. Ah, okay. Interessant.
Die hat für sich eine Grundregel formuliert, dass wenn ihr Senderprogramm auf dem Blatt geschrieben nicht lustig ist, dann ist es auch nicht lustig, wenn sie es performt.
Also ein guter Gag ist schon gut. Also es ist schon wichtig.
Okay.
Aber ich habe...
Wie viel glaubst du, kann man aus Arbeit macht baufrei noch rausholen durch die Performance?
Keine Ahnung, es ist dein Gag, es ist deine Idee, ich weiss es nicht.
Vielen Dank. Wie viel glaubst du, kann man aus Arbeit macht baufrei noch rausholen durch die Performance? Keine Ahnung, es ist dein Gag, es ist deine Idee, ich weiss es nicht.
Freut euch auf die nächste Folge.
Ja, den besten Arbeit macht baufrei-Gag aus aller Zeiten.
Wir sind gespannt. Stay tuned.
Ja, es ist spannend, es ist schon spannend, aber es ist halt nicht so wirklich.
Ich meine, wir sind ja schon auf so einer missionarischen Mission unterwegs, wo wir halt versuchen, Comedy und Stand-Up zu erklären, aber es ist halt einfach wahnsinnig nerdig, oder? Also ich habe das Gefühl, wir haben sehr viele Podcast-Ufo-Hörer in dieser Folge, auch so ein bisschen, die werden zuhören, die werden es interessant finden, aber es ist schon wahnsinnig nerdig. Also wenn ihr wirklich sagt, ihr wollt Comedy in irgendeiner Form weiterbringen oder ihr wollt irgendwas dazu tun, dann ... Das ist ja auch schon zu weit gebracht, wir wollen es ja erstmal nur verstehen. Wir wollen ja selber gucken, die Sache analysieren, damit man sich einfach einen Überblick macht und es einfach analysiert und durchdringt. Dann bringe ich eine Jerry Seinfeld-Anekdote. Sehr gut. Jetzt kommen wir doch langsam in die Zähne. Comedy ist, du hast eine Dartscheibe, dir werden die Augen verbunden und du versuchst zu treffen. Das ist Comedy. Du weisst es nicht. Du weisst nicht, ob aus einer Idee irgendwann mal solide Comedy wird. Das weisst du nicht. Du musst es halt machen. Der Prozess ist das Ziel. Tja, spannend. Wir bleiben dran. Hast du noch Fragen?
Und noch eine Sache, wenn ihr wirklich irgendwie an der Comedy was machen wollt oder irgendwie so, oder irgendwie denkt so, Comedy muss irgendwie anders betrachtet werden in Deutschland, dann redet auch so, als wäre es eine Kunstform oder behandelt es auch so. War das gerade ein Versuch, uns zu ändern, oder hast du das Gefühl, wir tun es schon? Oder das hängt also durch, als ob du denkst, dass wir nicht versuchen, das zu ändern oder so zu reden. Nein, ich habe das so gesagt. Okay. Aber kannst du dir vorstellen, dass du irgendwann keinen Bock mehr hast und dann nach Amerika ziehst und Englisch machst? Warum? Weil da vielleicht die bessere Crowd für dich ist oder das grössere potenzielle Publikum. Hast du nicht mal in England was gemacht? Das habe ich, glaube ich, gesehen. Also ich mache es auch immer noch auf Englisch. Ich bin jetzt nicht mehr so oft in San Francisco. Funktioniert Comedy besser in einer anderen Sprache als Deutsch? Kannst du nicht fragen, witzig ist witzig. Ich habe mal darüber was geschrieben, also für die Uni oder sowas, und da habe ich auch … Wirklich musste ich mich tief einlesen, weil es darüber nicht viel gibt, es gibt kaum wissenschaftliches Zeug, aber dann habe ich halt eine Sache gefunden. Rudi Carell hat, glaube ich, einen Grossteil der wissenschaftlichen Abwohnungen. Sehr viel mit Excel, warum man mit Experimentierli geschrieben hat. Und nee, da kam dann wirklich raus, dass der deutsche Satzbau einfach wahnsinnig uncool ist. Das hat Stuart Lee geschrieben, politischer Stand-Up-Comedian, der rausgefunden hat. Vielleicht haben das mehrere auch geschrieben. Dass du die Pornen in der deutschen Sprache nicht so effektiv manchmal bauen kannst. Beispiel, ist kein Witz, aber Fettes Brot hat einen Songtext, der beste Rapper Deutschlands ist offensichtlich ich. Also der Satz suggeriert bis zum letzten Wort noch was anderes. Der beste Rapper Deutschlands ist offensichtlich Bushido. Ist aber grammatikalisch eigentlich falsch. Das müsste heißen, der beste Rapper Deutschlands bin offensichtlich ich. Das heißt, bei dem dritten Wort hast du schon verraten, auf wen du anspielst. Das heißt, es ist ein einfaches Beispiel, um zu sagen, wahrscheinlich ist der deutsche Satzbau vielleicht ist für Comedy nicht so geil, wie zum Beispiel Englisch, kann man sagen. Deswegen ist in Amerika einfach die Vorreiter für Comedy. Oder du versuchst halt auf sehr krampfhafte Weise das deutsche Klischee zu bestätigen, dass sie lustig sind. Ja, genau, richtig. Das kann natürlich auch sein. Also ich meine, klar, jede Sprache hat, so, weißt du, aber ein arabischer Stand-up-Comedian wird sich auch irgendwie damit abfinden müssen und wird auch Wege finden, wie er das witzig formulieren kann. Ja, aber ist die Frage. Also ich glaube, Kultur und Sprache haben ja mega viel miteinander zu tun, aber es ist einfach auch so weit geht, dass man sagt, dass es nicht nur eine stumpfe Ausrede ist, sondern wirklich auch verwurzelt ist in der Kultur, in der Sprache, dass man einfach nicht so gut Geschichten erzählen kann in Deutsch wie in Englisch. Allein das Fehlen eines Fuck finde ich ist schon schreckenweise ein Problem. Also ich finde im Englischen wird einfach vieles lustig, weil du auch, was so ein bisschen deine Comedy-Persona ist, dieses Ragen, ich rege mich auf, das lässt sich einfach mit einem Fucking am Ende irgendwie besser beenden. Da hast du im Deutschen nicht so die grosse Möglichkeit. Verdammt. Ja, verdammt, das ist alles so ein bisschen halbger. Wie gesagt, es kommt alles drauf an, wie du siehst. Ihr könnt weiterhin diesen Podcast machen und versuchen herauszufinden, warum es hier nicht so toll ist wie in den Staaten. Nee, so reden wir gar nicht. Ich meine, der Grund, ich finde es gut, dass man hier nicht einfach so Fuck benutzen kann oder so, weil es zwingt dich dazu, bessere Jokes zu schreiben. Wenn du einen Witz hast, der sich auf Fuck stützt, dann ist die Idee da hinten. Das ist ein klassischer Bauchfrei-Gag, der ist einfach nicht gut. Der wahrscheinlich einfach nicht so. Ja, aber der wäre mit fucking besser. Arbeit macht fucking bauchfrei. Das ist ja auch nur ein Beispiel. Aber ganz kurz, warum ich gesagt habe, dass vielleicht Amerika eine Option wäre. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, dass allein schon die Grösse des potenziellen Publikums so eine Kunstform verbessern kann, weil du einfach sagst, hey, meine Comedy ist so speziell, ich spreche nur ein Prozent der Leute an, die finden mich aber richtig geil, erlaubt es mir in Amerika trotzdem noch genug Leute in die Säle oder meine DVD kaufen zu lassen, um genug Geld zu verdienen, wohingegen Deutschland ein Prozent einfach nicht genug ist, weil es schlicht nicht genug Menschen gibt. Das ist mir alles zu anstrengend. Das kannst du gerne so sehen, aber wenn du das selber machst, hier ist der ultimative Typ für Stand-up, ja? War lustig. Sei einfach besser als der Typ nach dir oder vor dir. Es ist total simpel, wenn du einfach so unfassbar lustig bist, dass erwachsene Männer anfangen zu heulen und deren Frauen ein Kind von dir wollen, dann ist es scheissegal, ob du nur ein Prozent des Publikums ansprichst.
Weil ich habe schon vor so vielen unterschiedlichen Arten vom Publikum abgeräumt und versagt, ja, das ist kein, witzig ist witzig, ja, natürlich gibt es Unterschiede und so, und wenn du einer 90-Jährigen versuchen erklären willst, was Game of Thrones ist, wirst du dich schwer tun, aber das ist ja oft nicht die Realität, du spielst ja oft immer, wenn du Glück hast, vor mehreren Leuten, ja, und da entscheiden sich halt dann andere Faktoren, und du, deswegen, ich habe mich immer nur, und das tue ich auch nach wie vor, nur darauf konzentriert, dass ich besser bin als die Comedians, die mit mir in der Show auftreten. Und wenn ich jemanden finde, der besser ist als ich, dann denke ich mir so, cool, was macht der anders? Okay. Alles klar. Das ist ein gutes Schlusswort. Wunderbar, vielen Dank. Maxi Schettenbauer, dass du da warst. Wie lange geht es? Schettentime? Auch eine Stunde, ne? Machst du auch eine Stunde? Die Solo-Folgen mache ich eine halbe Stunde, die Talk-Folgen gehen eine Stunde. Da muss ich dir ja meine Bewunderung ausdrücken. Solo-Folge finde ich echt krass. Ich wollte das auch mal machen, weil ich hatte früher, bevor ich Stefan kennengelernt habe, keine Freunde und dachte mir, ich will Podcast machen. Du hast immer noch keine Freunde. Okay, danke. Und habe dann immer angefangen, irgendwie Sachen zu erzählen, aber nach fünf Minuten kam ich mir einfach so unglaublich bescheuert vor, dass ich aufgehört. Ich meine, du redest mit deinen Katzen, von daher ist das natürlich ein ganz guter Ansprechpartner, aber das will ich nochmal sagen, finde ich cool, dass du das hinkriegst und dass du für dich deine Form gefunden hast, da einfach dein Zeug rauszuhauen. Und schaut ihn euch an, wenn ihr die Möglichkeit habt. Ich muss sagen, Quatsch, Comedy Club waren vier Ex-Star, du hast mir echt mit Abstand am besten gefallen. Danke sehr. Doch, kann kaum machen. Danke sehr, freut mich sehr. Vielen Dank für die Einladung. Ja, immer gerne. Viel Erfolg weiter. Ja, viel Erfolg auch dir, ne? Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Ciao. Kölner, äh, Kinderstuben bis Klorin-Wilson-Massiz. Was ist gerade passiert, wie hast du es erlebt? Ist die Frage, also das, was wir jetzt gerade aufnehmen. Schnellen wir das vor oder nach wie vor? Wir reden jetzt einfach mal. Wir reden einfach mal was und wir können ja später gucken, wie wir es verwenden und was immer. Okay, ich schneide es nicht ganz vorne ab. Wir können einfach mal gucken. Ich finde es total interessant und ich glaube auch, natürlich ist es immer diese altbekannte Sache, man kann, wenn man einmal in so einem Diskussionsduktor ist. Ja, ich weiß und ich habe mir tatsächlich genau im Vorhinein genau gedacht, dass das passieren wird. Ja, ich mir auch, aber habe es irgendwie auch nicht gedacht. Ich habe irgendwie auch gedacht, dass wir da leichter rauskommen.
Ja. So wie, weil ich habe immer gedacht, dass Gäste hier so auftreten wie Buckelberg und Oli P.
Einfach mal, dass die einzigen beiden Gäste waren, die bis jetzt da waren und die exakt gleich reagiert haben.
Die haben sich auf dieses Pornending eingelassen, so, und das kann man einfach jetzt nicht.
Einfach, weil er aber auch abgewichste Sau ist.
Ja, klar, natürlich.
Boah, mich hat es also spätestens, als er gesagt hat, ich soll mein Stand-up nicht machen, hat mich das so komplett rausgeworfen, weil ich komplett...
Ja, vor allem, du zeigst ihn gestern auch immer mit deiner Mimik, dass du das Gespräch gerade hasst, dass du gerade nicht hier sein willst.
Ja, ich weiß, aber ich habe mir die ganze Zeit überlegt, was ich mache, und ich haue mein Stand-up noch raus vor dir, ist mir scheißegal, ich habe es den Hörern versprochen, dass ich den Stand-up mache, und ich mache es auch einfach deswegen, und wir haben die ganze Zeit gelabert einfach, und ich hätte es halt irgendwie cool gefunden, wenn man irgendwas gehabt hätte, an dem man vielleicht so Dinge besprechen kann, dass ich sagen kann, hier und das, das hat nicht funktioniert, irgendwie, das ist ein klassischer Anfänger für, damit man so ein bisschen konkret an die Sache rangeht. Aber das hat halt, ich kann natürlich ihn verstehen, absolut klar, natürlich ist es der Ende des Lebens. Wir waren aber auch uncool. Wir waren total uncool. Wir weiss, warum wir uncool waren, weil wir nicht sagen, was uns gerade stört. Weil wir auch nicht sagen können, was uns stört. Ich kann zu dir in den Worten fassen, was sich stört. Und zwar kann ich in den Worten fassen. Mich stört es, dass er sagt, die Comedy-Mannschaft in Deutschland hat einen scheiß Ruf, Aber dann, aber dann, aber sich dann aufführen hier, als wäre man der Comedy-Gott und wüsste genau, was gerade läuft, aber mega ernst ist. Aber das ist so, die Comedians in Amerika sehe ich in Talkshows nur, wie sie mega abliefern. Und Leute, auch Nils Buckelberg war für mich mehr Comedian und er ist doch sein Job, er wird eingeladen an den Posten. Aber das ist nicht sein Problem, das war nicht sein Fehler, das war unser Fehler, weil wir in diese Diskussionskultur gekommen sind. Wir haben schon Powering geredet. Es ist halt einfach nicht so einfach lustig zu sein, wenn du über Comedy redest, weil es halt einfach, und ich finde, da zeigt sich auch eine Leidenschaft, dass er halt nicht in den Sinn mal reingerutscht. Nein, aber also erstens, das Problem war, dass wir auch diesen Missionarscharakter plötzlich angenommen haben, als wären wir dieser Podcast, der versucht, die deutsche Podcast-Szene zu revolutionieren, was einfach Schwachsinn ist, wo wir einfach in diesem Arroganz von oben herunter von der Kanzlei, wir würden jetzt Deutschland zum großen Stand-Up-Olympik kommen. Nein, das sagen wir immer aus Spaß, aber das kann man gar nicht an. Ja, aber er hat keine einzige Folge gehört, der dachte, das ist Folge 32 eines Podcasts, in dem wir jedes Mal darüber reden, warum die deutsche Podcast-Szene scheiße ist. Und da kann ich natürlich nachvollziehen, dass er sagt, ja, es hat keinen Sinn, ständig nur darüber zu labern, warum alles scheiße ist, wo er vollkommen recht hat, was ja überhaupt nicht unser Ansatz ist. Aber warum sagst du denn, ich habe nie gedacht, ich war noch nie in dem Punkt. Du hast so oft das Wort missionieren, ja, wir versuchen ja auch zu missionieren, wir versuchen null zu missionieren. Auf Spaß habe ich es immer gesagt. Ja, aber das kam überhaupt nicht rüber. Und ich ich dachte, warum wenn das so auffällt, dass es so rüberkommt, wie es mir nicht aufgefallen ist, dann sag doch einen Ton. Ja, aber ich kann ja nicht sagen, hey Stefan, hey, pass mal auf, dass was du sagst, kommt der Schwachsinn. Du hast dann dauernd jeder vorgesagt, das tauchen mal. Ja, gut, aber das ist was anderes, wenn du hast, und ich meine, wir waren auch so fucking unlustig, ey, es ist überhaupt nicht so gegangen. Nee, ich fand nicht das Video lustig. Na ja, doch schon, ich hätte ein paar gute Sagen rausgehauen, das war kein Problem. Überhaupt war die überhaupt nicht. Dafür, dass das Gespräch an sich eher ernst war. Ich gehe schon aus, wenn ich mit einem Comedian spreche, dass er abliefert. Nein, aber das ist ein Fehler, das ist dein Fehler. Ja, das kann mal fehler sein. Der ist hier nicht, um zu performen, um sein Stand-Up-Programm abzureißen. Doch, er ist hier da, um zu performen. Nein, ist er nicht, er ist da, um zu performen. Leute wie wir. Und ich meine, wenn wir ihn performt hätten und Riesendinger, hätte er vielleicht eingestiegen. Aber wir haben uns auch mit ihm unterhalten und das steckt natürlich ein. Du kannst nicht davon erwarten, dass nur weil jemand Stand-Up-Communitant ist, dass es hier reinkommt und die grosse Sache abzieht. Wir bezahlen ihn nicht dafür, das ist nicht sein Job, und er hat ein paar Gags gemacht und ich finde, er ist ein lustiger Typ und ein super sympathischer Typ, kann man machen, aber dass er jetzt auch von sich aus performt, das ist das Problem des Hosts, dass man ihm nicht die Möglichkeit gibt, zu performen. Ja, ist es. Fand ich nicht, dass wir es nicht gegeben haben. Ich erwarte von lustigen Leuten, dass man eine Frage stellt. Also ich zum Beispiel, wenn ich irgendwo eingenaden werde, habe ich das Bedürfnis, zu performen. Du hast es genauso, das weiß ich. Wir haben beide das Gefühl, immer einen Gags rauszuhauen zu nehmen. Ja, aber gut, aber er macht das halt seit sechs Jahren. Das ist halt so, der braucht das halt nicht mehr vielleicht. Ach, glaube ich nicht. Auch wenn so ein Louis C. K. irgendwo eingeladen wird in so einem Gammel-Podcast. Ja, aber dann kriegt er auch ab. Ja, gut, aber dann kriegt, ja, weiß ich nicht. Doch, die fangen auch ab, weil es einfach ihr Ding ist, weil es ihr Leben ist. Naja, aber ich würde nicht sagen, dass es sein Fehler ist, ehrlich gesagt. Ich würde sagen, wir hätten schon was rausgekommen. Es ist halt auch, ich weiß nicht warum, aber es ist halt einfach, man kommt halt manchmal oft einfach nicht in so ein Gespräch rein. Es ist halt von Anfang an so ein Ding und es läuft nicht und das kann man natürlich jetzt jedem in die Schuhe schieben, aber es ist halt einfach nicht da. Glaubst du, es liegt daran, dass wir mit Gästen nicht klarkommen, die unseren Podcast noch nicht gehört haben?
Ich weiß nicht, also ich meine, es war jetzt kein furchtbares
Ding, aber es wäre halt mehr so eine Interviewgeschichte
als jetzt ein lockerer Talk, aber ich glaube,
dass man durchaus da Sachen besser machen kann,
um in die Sache reinzukommen, dass man sich vielleicht Sachen überlegt,
ich habe mir Sachen überlegt, die halt nicht angekommen sind,
die nicht angenommen wurden und nicht umgesetzt wurden,
wo ich dachte, man kann vielleicht ein bisschen was drauf
ein, ein, ein, wir sind mit dem Gaming-Thema
eingestiegen, wo wir erst mal 20 Minuten
über die Wie gesprochen haben, wo ich mega lost habe,
wo ich die Hälfte, wo ich nicht wusste, sind wir jetzt in einem
Vielen Dank. Man kann vielleicht ein bisschen was drauf ein... Wir sind mit dem Gaming-Thema eingestiegen, wo wir erst mal 20 Minuten über die Wie gesprochen haben.
Wo ich mega lost war. Wo ich die Hälfte, wo ich nicht wusste, sind wir jetzt in einem Comedy-Ding drin oder rede er jetzt ernsthaft oder versuche er jetzt so ironisch seine Rolle als Gamer zu erfüllen?
Wo sind wir gerade? Ich war vollkommen verloren.
Ja, ich auch.
Und vor allem über das Thema kann man gut reden, deswegen haben wir weitergeredet, was ein Fehler war.
Wir hätten eigentlich zu allgemeineren Themen hinführen müssen, wo wir gesagt hätten, da kann man eher lustige Sachen drüber machen, die Leute einfach generell verstehen. In kurz, wir entschuldigen uns für die letzte Stunde. Auf eine Hostart, doch, ich finde, wir haben als Host heute versagt. Aber auf der anderen Seite müsste ich auch nichts besser machen. Wenn ich jetzt die Zeitmaschine hätte und zurückfahren könnte, vor einer Stunde noch was, dann glaube ich, wäre ich genauso überfordert mit der Situation. Ja, es war halt ein wahnsinnig theoretisches Gespräch, was an sich nicht schlimm ist, weil uns die Theorie natürlich auch interessiert. Und da finde ich, kann man auch mal sagen, ob das Publikum das jetzt so wahnsinnig interessiert. Klar, das ist ja genau das Thema, was wir angesprochen haben. So dieses, redest du über das, was beim Publikum ankommt, oder redest du über das, was dich selber interessiert. Und es interessiert uns ja, und ich glaube, man findet auch sein Publikum, dass die Leute, die auch Bock drauf haben, da irgendwie hängenbleiben. Ich würde aber schon sagen, dass wir gute Zitate aus dem herausbekommen haben, und das wäre auch eigentlich unser Main-Goal, so, wenn der große Gast, der große Stand-Upper, den wir wirklich gut finden, Max Stettenbauer hier ist, dass wir dann auch mit ihm über Dinge reden, wie einfach Stand-Up-Handwerk sind. Da kann man aber auch lustig drüber reden. Na, ich weiß, also ich habe auch anderperformed auf jeden Fall. Ich war auch teilweise wirklich schreckenweise komplett lost. Und es ist halt wirklich schwer, weil unser Stil halt so ein bisschen darauf basiert, dass man sich Dinge hin und her wirft und halt auch so aufbaut und aneinander einklingt, was halt schwer ist. Was auch mir ja uncool ist, das zu sagen, aber im Prinzip ist es wie so eine Art Impro-Ding. Wir sind doch ein Open-Mic-Mikrotag. Aber wir können halt nicht unser Ding durchziehen, wenn wir ansonsten den Gasthaltkommen mit außen vor lassen würden. Haben wir was so gemerkt, aber bei Oli Perz auch funktioniert. Das hat mich von vornherein in die falsche Ecke geführt. Aber ich glaube, die waren ein bisschen mehr involviert. Und vielleicht war auch einfach zu viel Respekt da, dass wir gesagt haben, wir müssen jetzt ihm, sag ich mal, einbinden, Plattformen geben, anstatt dass er sagt, er sucht sich seine eigenen Pointen und seine eigenen Möglichkeiten, ins Gespräch einzukommen. Vielleicht hätten wir müssen jetzt ihm sag ich mal einbinden, Plattform geben, anstatt dass er sagt, er sucht sich seine eigenen
Pointen und seine eigenen Möglichkeiten, ins Gespräch
einzukommen. Vielleicht hätten wir da eher, sag ich mal,
selbstbewusst unser eigenes Ding fahren müssen,
ohne ihn jetzt... Ich war mega da überfordert.
Da ist jetzt jemand mit einem geballten
Wissen, der aber einfach
das ganz trocken
runterbeetet, was er weiss,
und mega reflektiert ist, mega gut
Übersicht hat, aber leider einfach nicht lustig ist dabei. Ja, obwohl ich nicht sage, dass das nicht immer sein muss, aber ich finde, die Gesprächssituation war halt so komisch. Wir waren einerseits die Fragenden, die wissen wollen, wie es läuft, andererseits wussten wir schon selber genau, wie es laufen soll und hatten unsere Meinungen und es war nicht so ganz klar, wo das jetzt hingeht irgendwie. Wir haben schon gefragt, in dem Sinne, dass wir es wissen wollten, wir haben jetzt immer gesagt, dass wir missionarisch unterwegs sind und die Weltretter spielen wollen. Wir waren wieder auf Augenhöhe, noch war eine klare ... Ne, wir waren nicht auf Augenhöhe, aber es war auch keine klare Er- oder Wir-Situation, wer oben und unten war. Ne, es war schon eine, wir wollen wissen, wie es läuft, Nummer, die aber irgendwann nicht so rüberkam, weil wir einfach versucht haben, Bälle ihm zuzuspielen. Das hat sie ein bisschen kaputt gemacht. Wir haben halt ein Problem damit, mit ernsten Situationen, mit ernsten Gesprächen kommen wir beide nicht klar. Weil wir generell den Druck haben, zu performen und Gags machen. Weil wir generell den Druck haben, Comedy zu machen. Ja, aber ist es unser Problem, dass wir dann nicht die Comedy rauskriegen, oder ist es das Problem der Situation, dass es an uns liegt, dass wir halt einfach ständig Gags machen wollen und halt alles lustig machen wollen. Wir können ja auch über ernste Themen reden, ich weiß nicht, so uninteressant fand ich es, ich war wahrscheinlich einfach stark abgelenkt und konnte dem Gespräch nicht wirklich folgen, weil ich mir die ganze Zeit dachte, okay, fuck, wo führt das jetzt hin, warum kann ich meinen Stand-Up nicht machen, ich war die erste Hälfte mega aufgeregt, weil ich meinen Stand-Up machen wollte und die zweite Hälfte war ich fucking mega semi-piss, semi-erleichtert, aber halt auch unbefriedigt, so von wegen, ja, fuck it, jetzt habe ich das alles gemacht und für nichts irgendwie. Schade, schade, es wäre halt, ich mache den Stand-up noch, fuck it. Ja, mach gerne nochmal, ich werde auch was vorbereiten. Nee, ich mache ihn jetzt. Nein. Ich habe es, nein, ich habe es dem Publikum. Es ist 21.21 Uhr, ich habe keinen Bock mehr. Das ist mir scheißegal, das sind fünf Minuten. Ich habe den ganzen Tag da, aber der Kopfschmerz, der ist so warm in den Augen. Fuck it, ja gut, dann ist es mir egal, dann gehe ich aus, dann mache ich ihn alleine. Aber ich habe dem Publikum versprochen. Du machst den nächsten, warum du willst. Nein, ich habe dem Publikum versprochen, dass ich es diese Woche mache. Ich nehme diese. Nein, aber das war doch der ganze Sinn der Sache, dass man eine Deadline hat und ansonsten wird man das wieder ständig verschiebt und so. Aber du hast was geschrieben, das gibt mir auch was. Nein, aber ich muss es auch performen, um zu sehen. Und dann ist halt das Publikum dann der Kritiker und kann sagen, ob es scheiss ist oder nicht. Oder du kannst es sagen oder nicht. Aber ist mir egal, wir können es ja auch, wenn es wirklich überhaupt nicht reinpasst, dann schneiden wir es raus. Aber ich will das jetzt machen einfach so, weil sonst fühle ich mich scheiße, weil sonst fühle ich mich, als würde ich jetzt mit einer Halberektion hier rumsitzen und halt würde nicht zum Zug kommen. Denn von mir aus dann gehe ich raus. Dann mache ich es alleine. Und dann kann das Publikum entscheiden. Ich stelle das Mikro jetzt weg ich höre jetzt fünf Minuten lang zu. Aber du hast wirklich nur fünf Minuten und ich werde einen Teile stellen und wenn du überziehst ... Aber wenn's wirklich ... nein, nein, nein, das kannst du nicht machen, du musst mir schon meine Zeit ... Nein. Ich weiss nicht genau, wie lange es dauert. Du hast fünf Minuten, das war die Regel, du hast fünf Minuten zu deiner Vorbereitung, wenn fünf Minuten vorbei sind, brech ich dich ab. Okay, das ist jetzt die fucking schlechteste ... Ja, und ich bin auch mega sauer gerade und ich hoffe, dass du versagt, schuldig mich. Das ist mir egal. Mir scheissegal. Du musst unter den schlechtest möglichen ... Nein, nein, Moment, Moment, Moment. Du machst Jobs, aber lass mich halt einfach alles machen. Ja, okay, und ... Warte, lass mich alles machen. Das ist scheisse, wenn ich da mitten in dem Ding ohne die Pointe ... Hey, ich breche ab. Ja, aber dann beeile ich mich. Dann beeile ich mich. Das ist auch scheisse. Drei. Nein, lass das einfach so machen. Ich stopp nicht. Ich weiss nicht genau, wie lange es dauert. Und? Dann fang zumindest mit dem Applaus ein, wenn ich rauskomme. Okay, lass mich hier rauskommen. Moderier mich an und applaudiere. Meine Damen und Herren, ich begrüsse Sie ganz herzlich zu Holocaust-Gags, Kindervergewaltigungs-Gags und vielleicht auch ein bisschen Spaß mit unserem Newcomer. Er ist zum ersten Mal auf der Bühne. Läuft die Zeit schon die ganze Zeit, oder was? Die Zeit läuft schon. Ich muss sagen, wir freuen uns alle, ihn zum ersten Mal auf der Stand-Up-Bühne begrüssen zu dürfen. Meine Damen und Herren, begrüssen Sie Florentin Will. Dankeschön, dankeschön, vielen Dank, dankeschön, schön, dass ihr da seid, vielen Dank. Ja, ich schaue in letzter Zeit gar nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viel Fernsehen, was aber tatsächlich auch ein bisschen schade ist irgendwie, weil man auch wahnsinnig viel verpasst, was man dann nachts beim Rumseppen irgendwie finden könnte. Habe ich letztens zum Beispiel gesehen, Blindenfussball. Ja, interessant, blinde Leute spielen Fussball,
und zwar in dem...
Halt die Fresse jetzt, halt die Fresse.
Ich fang nochmal an.
Du kannst nicht einfach in das Ding reinreden.
Das geht nicht.
Ich werde es live kommentieren.
Applaudier nochmal.
Und ausser Lachen hast du keine fucking Reaktionsmöglichkeit. Du kannst nicht einfach ins Mikrofon sprechen. Das kannst du bei einem Stand-Up-Auftritt auch nicht machen. Doch, ich bin dafür... Nein, kannst du nicht. eine Klingel drin ist, die dann immer klingelt, wenn der Ball sich bewegt und so können die Spieler den Ball hören und Fussball spielen. Das war ein relativ einseitiges Spiel, das ich gesehen habe, 7 zu 0. Ich frage mich dann immer, was passiert nach dem Spiel? Kommen dann die ganzen Spieler nochmal in die Kabine zum Trainer und hören sich das Spiel danach nochmal an? So von wegen hier bei Minute 13 hast du nach dem Tor einen Gegenspieler umarmt, was war da los? Minute zwanzig hast du zum Hotdog-Vufer gepasst, bei Minute 38 hat der Schiedsrichter drei Tore geschossen, was war da los? Ich meine, die Hälfte der Mannschaft ist bei Minute 60 aus dem Stadion gelaufen, wo sind die jetzt? Hat da mal jemand nachgeschaut. Ich habe letztens auf der Straße so einen kleinen Hund gesehen mit einer Klingel um den Hals und da habe ich mir auch gedacht, als blinden Fussballspieler, glaube ich, musst du echt aufpassen, dass da nicht einfach der Reflex übernimmt.
Einen Hund habe ich gesehen an einer Ampel und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt an einer Ampel.
Ich finde es immer erstaunlich, wie unglaublich ehrgeizig manche Menschen manchmal an einer Ampel werden und zwar gerade an den Ampeln, wo so ein gelber Drücker ist, der eigentlich keinen Drücker hat, sondern die Ampel funktioniert alleine, man kann gar nicht drücken, aber es gibt trotzdem immer irgendeinen, der an dem Ampeldrücker rumsteht und einfach drauf rumdrückt und irgendwo jedes Element von diesem Ampeldrücker abdrückt und versucht, da irgendwas hinzukriegen. Aber es funktioniert nicht, aber er drückt da einfach rum mit Wut und Kraft, als ob da irgendwie ein Schalter versteckt wäre, der noch irgendwie ein drittes Ampelmännchen freischaltet. Der drückt da rum, obwohl es überhaupt keinen Drücker gibt, den man drücken könnte. Also, falls ihr euch fragt, wie mein erstes Mal ablief, ziemlich genau so. Aber, na gut, ich meine, was heißt erstes Mal? Ich meine, meine sexuellen Erfahrungen beschränken sich eigentlich darauf, dass ich bei einem Umzug mal mit einer Frau zusammen eine Matratze getragen habe. Ich weiß nicht, ob das was zählt, ob das als erste Base zählt. Naja, ich habe jetzt bald zum Glück wieder ein Date, freue ich mich sehr darauf, und zwar gehe ich zu Subway
als Date. Ja, ich weiß, ich,
kleiner Romantiker, bringen Sie
uns bitte den teuersten Macadamia-Cookie,
den Sie da haben. Aber
wir müssen uns wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen beeilen mit dem Date, weil
vielleicht gibt es Subway ja gar nicht mehr
bald. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gehört habt mit dem Kinderpornoskandal
bei Subway. Es wurden
Kinderpornos in dem Subway, in dem Fuck, jetzt habe ich mich mich bei der Pornoversch. Das ist so weit. Fick dich. Halt die Fresse jetzt. Kinderpornoskandal. Wir müssen uns ein bisschen beeilen, weil vielleicht gibt's Subway bald gar nicht mehr und wird zugemacht. Halt die Fresse jetzt! Was soll ich denn machen, wenn du reinredest? Also, wir müssen uns ein bisschen beeilen, weil vielleicht gibt's Subway bald gar nicht mehr. Vielleicht habt ihr es gehört von dem Kinderpornoskandal. Es wurden nämlich Kinderpornos in einem Sandwich gefunden. Und Kinderporno ist natürlich immer wahnsinnig schwierig. Da ist natürlich ganz schnell dann die Sache abgehakt. Da fragt jemand mehr lange nach. Zum Beispiel habe ich mich gefragt, was ist da eigentlich genau mit Pluto passiert, dass Pluto kein Planet mehr ist. Was genau ist da eigentlich vorgefallen? Und ich stelle es mir so vor, dass sie, als die Wissenschaftler das erste Mal ein Teleskop entwickelt haben, mit dem man die Oberfläche des Pluto beobachten konnte, und die Wissenschaftler das erste Mal durchschauen, schauen sie sich Pluto an, Staub, leere Welt, komplett einöde Krater, Und in einem Krater, ganz verl, eine DVD-Hülle, Paulas Grundschulabenteuer Teil 5. Natürlich ganz schlecht, die Wissenschaftler natürlich sofort, fuck, das konnten wir nicht wissen, Kinderpornos auf Pluto, da müssen wir irgendwas machen, die müssen wir natürlich sofort aus dem Planeten rausschmeißen, wo ist das passiert. Armer Pluto, kann man sagen. Ich meine, ich habe zu Hause bei meiner Familie über den Esstisch hängt immer noch so ein Sonnensystem, ein altes Sonnensystem mit Pluto und ich denke mir jedes Mal, wenn ich den Pluto sehe, du kleiner, dreckiger Pluto, was gleichzeitig auch der Titel von einem meiner Lieblingskinderpornos ist. Naja, auf jeden Fall, naja, ich freue mich, dass das Date gut läuft.
Ich bin tatsächlich gar nicht, weil ich habe immer so ein bisschen Probleme mit Dates, ich bin gar nicht so gut im Daten. Und deswegen lese ich mir auch immer wahnsinnig gerne solche Tipps durch. Fünf Tipps, wie ihr beim ersten Date gut landen könnt. Und da habe ich letztens einen Artikel gelesen von so einem Wissenschaftler, der meinte, was Menschen besonders gut zusammenschweißt, sind das gemeinsame Erleben von Extremsituationen.
Er hat dann so einen Fall beschrieben, wie so ein Mann und eine Frau in einer eingestürzten Höhle zusammengelebt haben und die dann auch rausgekommen sind, überlebt haben und später geheiratet haben und heute glücklich leben. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, vielen Dank für diesen Tipp, wie genau soll ich das jetzt umsetzen, wie soll das aussehen? soll ich am nächsten Tag im Büro dann schauen, hey, na, wir haben uns gerade am Kopierer so nett unterhalten irgendwie, du hast mir erzählt, dass du gern wieder Banjo spielen möchtest, wie in deiner Kindheit, hat mir echt gut gefallen, hast du vielleicht Lust, mit mir irgendwie nächstes Wochenende in einer rostigen Seilbahn zu fahren oder so? Ja, ich hoffe wirklich, dass das Date gut läuft. Meine letzte Freundin war irgendwie ein bisschen komisch tatsächlich, muss man sagen. Die hat zum Beispiel immer beim Obst hat sie immer nur diesen kleinen Papiersticker gegessen und das eigentliche Obst weggeworfen. Das war ein bisschen komisch. Und? Und sie hat den Piranha als Haustier. Ja, was total interessant ist, aber sie hat dann immer bei jeder Gelegenheit ständig erwähnt, ja, Piranhas sind ja gar nicht so gefährlich, weil Piranhas töten weniger Menschen als Bienen pro Jahr.
Ja, und da habe ich mir immer gedacht, wow, wow, wow, langsam, langsam, du kannst jetzt nicht einfach eine komplette Tierart in einen Kessel werfen, das geht nicht, du kannst nicht einfach sagen, Bienen töten so viel und Piranien töten so viel, ich meine, es sind ja trotzdem noch einzelne, individuelle Tiere, die töten. Vielleicht ist es die ein und dieselbe Biene, die 2013 16.000 Menschen getötet hat, vielleicht … Ich will Namen, ja. Oder ich meine zum Beispiel, wie muss ja diese Statistik aussehen? Gibt's dann zum Beispiel ein Jahr, wo eine Tierart komplett ausflippt, irgendwie 2013, die Nilpferde, 16-mal so viele Menschen getötet wie im Jahr davor. Was war da los? Und ich meine, natürlich gibt es bei Tieren genauso Vollidioten wie bei Menschen auch, die dann natürlich dafür verantwortlich sind, dass die Statistik irgendwie aus dem Rahmen sprengt. Ich meine, was ist denn, was passiert, wenn so eine einsame, dusselige, schüsselige Schildkröte plötzlich einen Zug entgleisen lässt? Zack, 500 Menschen tot, die Statistik ist ruiniert. Mensch, Erwin, was
war das denn?
Guter Closer.
Vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit. Dankeschön.
Wir bedanken uns bei Flo und Hinwild, unserem Newcomer.
Dankeschön.
Vielen Dank.
Willst du direkt
Feedback geben?
Ich würde mir das nochmal an und in der nächsten Folge entspannt Feedback geben. Ich denke, das war ein guter Closer. Wir bedanken uns bei Maxi Schettenbauer. Arschloch, ey, da stehe ich hier da wie ein Depp und du rödelst die ganze Zeit rein. Das ist echt scheiße. Gott, Gott, Gott, Gott. Ja, das Ganze hat nicht so funktioniert, das war irgendwie ein bisschen, die Aufnahmesituation war ein bisschen blöd, ich habe ein sehr teures Mikrofon kaputt gemacht, irgendwie die Stimmung war ein bisschen angespannt, wir haben in einer Eichel-Dose Booster gelegt. Ganz kurz zu dem Zellen habe ich gesagt, ich war sehr gemein und ich habe versucht, das Ganze noch so ein bisschen auf so eine Publikumsebene zu heben, indem ich wirklich auch ein bisschen so Druck gemacht habe und das wäre auch was das Publikum mit dir auch machen würde und ich dachte mir, das hilft. Ja, ich glaube, dass das Publikum ständig ironisch lacht. Und das wäre auch was das Publikum mit dir auch machen würde. Und ich dachte mir, das hilft.
Ja, ich glaube, dass das Publikum ständig ironisch lacht.
Das ist das, was das Publikum, ahaha, war das lustig, glaube ich,
dass es genau so wie ein normales, natürliches Publikum reagieren würde.
Ja, vielen Dank, dass ihr mit dabei wart in dieser erneuten Schicksalsnacht.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, haut rein, wir heben ab.